you think the ravens going to the super  bowl oh man now listen  you see the enthusiasm and the  motivation what does that mean they're  playing as a team  see they couldn't play as a team with  flacco  because flacco didn't have nothing to do  with the players at all so what about  the charges you know i think the charge  is going to be yeah no you don't listen  phillip rivers you don't even have to  worry  the river's a hall of famer listen that  don't make no difference this guy's a  heisman trophy winner and he black so he  had to be better than all the white boys  now i don't know what that mean that nah  huh cause you got two heisman trophy  winners over there now he played a  heisman trophy winner last week and beat  him  he played a heisman trophy last week but  phillip rivers a hall of famer though  and we got antonio we got two hall of  famers on our team  oh okay you hear that you had to see  creole rivers tomorrow yes sir i got to  go see philly rivers okay well listen